sans surprise arnaud richard député de
la 7e circonscription des yvelines a été
élu samedi président de l'udps et
départementales le mouvement de jean
louis borloo
il obtient 97% des voix pour le nouveau
président de l'udps et il a priorité de
préparer activement les municipales dans
quelques jours les responsables de l'ue
dei par territoire seront ainsi connu
d'ores et déjà des membres composent
l'instance départementale à l'image de
joël le nom du parti radical à voisins
le bretonneux et pierre leguérinel
représentant l'alliance centriste à
maurepas se trouvent également
représentées au sein de l'ue dei
départementale la gauche moderne le
centre national des indépendants et
paysans la force européenne démocrate et
le nouveau centre
une large alliance c'est d'ailleurs ce
qu'a rappelé pierre leguérinel invités
du 7 8 1 mais je pense qu'à lui dit la
porte est fermée à très peu de gens
savaient en dehors des mouvements
extrémistes qui hérisse le poil de tout
républicain je vois pas pourquoi tu
avances il faudrait fermer les portes